hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to fire watch now
birdie is in there very creepy and i've
got turnt reynolds bernie and birdie
bernie bernie and turt reynolds and i'm
apparently a bond villain that's going
to be a really funny drawing when i
finally
or hopefully finally meet julia i really
hope and this is me predicting the
future like i do sometimes you know
because i'm a genius and everything and
i need to be building a window and i
totally forgot what i'm supposed to be
doing but i'm hoping
very much so that it's not going to be
the circumstance where i go to her area
because something horrible has happened
because it seems like there might be a
psychotic psycho
somewhere
in this forest and that's not okay
thong thunk don't even need nails i just
hammered it physically into the window
form frame i was a carpenter
you know it's once you get high enough
level of carbohydrate window up don't do
anything so
what should i do now what's next
what's next what do you think is next
well you've been the one giving me tasks
for two days straight
what's next is you sit in that room
until september 1st and call me at the
first sign of smoke
oh god yeah why don't you let me know
when you're mentally prepared uh
i'll give it to you oh god
oh god no i'm gonna lose my mind
psychotically i was the psycho i'm the
crazy okay anyway enough psychotic-ness
i've got bernie for that forest burns
how are you going
it's gonna be okay all right so there's
gotta be something else around here
something else that could be manly
thermos very appropriate there's got to
be something else that i'm missing
unless there's absolutely not
uh do i need to type it all pick my
typewriter report window is fine books
and
worry okay okay i'm ready okay i think i
am ready to tackle my long-term
commitment of keeping this national
forest safe from total destruction good
nice scripture i am glad to hear you've
really thought this through uh-huh
yeah
you know i'm gonna hike around for a
while before i really put my nose at the
grindstone
yeah you do that
okay really ready now wait what would i
do if i was hiking around is it it's
gonna flash forward to september first
is there gonna be a whole lot of nothing
that's going on i'm gonna go out of my
mind if i don't know what i'm doing okay
so if i'm
really thinking about this i guess like
what else would i do i don't really have
any idea of what i'm supposed to be
doing i mean now that i have ropes and
everything i should be able to get to
where i need to go but
till then i guess
i guess i i i i guess i'm ready okay
now i'm ready let's go to work okay good
now get to work
oh
what now
what the hell
well i didn't know that was gonna be the
thing that was gonna happen
what is that
is that supposed to happen how did i
just fast forward through time
having a nice afternoon oh god it's
gorgeous
i might never leave
well
uh
i called with some bad news
two young women chelsea stevens and lily
mclean were reported missing
they've got parents out in california
who haven't heard from him in a week
they were supposed to meet an aunt down
in cody if they're the girls from last
week then
you're probably the last person to have
seen him oh no
uh
you should tell whoever that i'm happy
to be questioned
look it's not gonna be an issue uh i
mean if if they turn up dead then maybe
should i just not say anything and save
us the trouble
i
i think it's worth mentioning it's worth
mentioning of course it is
yeah
i'll uh
i'll keep it vague i i really don't want
to talk to the cops
me neither all right henry thanks enjoy
the sunset i was having such a good time
over here worrying about time moving
forward oh god oh the time oh lordy lou
oh no
man so something happened to those girls
henry wake up okay got it
bernie's still there
hello
i've been keeping it back
up the radio you got it in my own time
hello there
how are you doing it's good to see you
but trouble lurks around every corner
okay all right then
what do you want
hey
you big dumb idiots what
hi jules
oh you sound tired
um i am
are you having a nice time
yeah
it's good here
it's beautiful you know
that's great henry
really great
well
i'll let you get back to sleep then
okay jules
delilah seems nice
sure
bye baby
wow
um too much of a pain in the ass to
bring supplies all the way up to our
towers
well i get my stuff hand delivered oh
how's that work
it's the perks of a decade of service
you're out hiking in 90 degree heat and
i get to do crosswords isn't life
miserably unfair
anyway when you find the supply drop
remember it's not just for you okay
other lookouts biologists a few people
get their food there and
i don't want to have to call in for more
there should be loads of good stuff
though beans prunes
jerky
you know my sister eats six prunes a day
six she's like really precise about it
she'd be great at this job if she didn't
need wheelbarrows full of marijuana to
function
i have nothing to comment about that i
have no opinion on the subject i am
walking like
two weeks ago you called me in the
middle of the night
you were sleeping i guess and
all i heard was the name jules through
the mumbles
i just thought it was so sweet i wanted
to wake you up but then i thought
maybe you were having a nice
conversation and
i'd just be spoiling it
what i hope you're doing okay
you know when it comes to her
i am
good
i'm glad
good mechanical conversations so a
couple of months before i took this job
i
i was with this guy
javier
he's incredible caring you sexy as hell
he was a driller down in casper is that
a euphemism we dated for almost five
years
i was working with the wyoming outdoor
leadership school and
i was obsessed with it
i wanted to be an instructor so badly
and i was sure i was going to marry
javier as soon as i could be bothered
wallace was also a good excuse to
get out of town drink whiskey in the
mountains cut loose
then um
javier's brother got killed working in
gillette and
some reason
i didn't come home
javier said it was fine he'd go to the
funeral take care of his mom stuff like
that it'd be easier solo
when he came back he left me
i came out here i lied and
told my sister he [ __ ] our neighbor
so
i lied to you i came out here with a
broken heart just like you
i figured you've told me so much about
you
so
you know there's something about me
we both [ __ ] up
man this got really heavy really quickly
i mean like really heavy that's a lot of
information to drop on somebody but i'm
assuming over the 33 days of the past
and i'm assuming i got turt reynolds and
a terrarium in my butt
that everything is a-okay and we're
getting to know each other very well but
again i have no opinion on that whatever
you said it was like wind in my ears
okay wait which am i
i am
two forks look out okay so this in the
middle is mine i'm not gonna be greedy
about it i don't even know if i can
carry it with me nope shoved it up my
butt just like everything else okay
so
it's a lot cash
found the supplies
go good
uh enjoy all right i got everything i
need out of here
time to chow down
just yours right
who do you think i am oh how dare you
okay
that's a big jump in time are we gonna
get some more information about the
missing girls because that seems to be
pertinent to the situation
oh god no for what might be the biggest
fire of the year oh boy yeah it's really
going
i'm gonna call it in
they'll send in a hot shot crew for some
suppression but
i bet we'll be stuck with her for the
rest of the
summer and
she doesn't have a name yet
i usually think of something funny or
something practical or a little risque
when coming up with them
but why don't you do the honors oh gosh
that's that's a big big fire flapjack
fire what about delilah
the flapjack fire
no ideas huh
delilah
uh delilah's a nice name
no you big dummy oh
i was kidding
no you were not
you're sweet but we can't call it the
delilah fire
okay what then
how about my middle name june
the june fire
even though it's july
i like it oh the name changed all right
then
wait so we're gonna be stuck there's
this creek down the hill and um
you know what my favorite thing to do is
skinny dip is it skinny dip what's that
it's skinny dipping i love to take a
bottle of whatever i have on hand plunge
it deep into the water and let it chill
in there all day
and then on nice like tonight when it is
so disgustingly hot
i have something nice and cool to drink
i learned that from my sister in santa
fe
she'd do that with a bottle of tequila
near her house and make margaritas the
size of your head that's so good
oh whoa flirty time if i was there with
you i'm
sure i would like it a lot
are you looking at the fire
yeah i am
i love how they look at night
during the day it's just smoke but when
the sun is down you can just
get lost
i'm glad you're here
me too
good
i don't talk to the other lookouts as
much as i talk to you
not in the same way
i know it's
probably been a while since you've
connected with someone the way we have
i don't mean to get all heavy but
it's been really nice
i wish i was over there
i wish you were too
we could sit outside
we could talk
about these radios we could um
you know
someone's probably listening in what
what could we do well
let me tell you
oh
well
that took a turn i mean i didn't have to
select those options obviously without a
license please find me fish and i'm sick
of all the stuff i got to eat
no i won't tell anyone you're a poacher
i'm a dirty rotten poacher i keep
hearing reports from fish and game about
a problem there they're trying to keep
tabs on can you search around the lake
for fresh tracks and just let me know
what you find
there was a crew burning fire lines out
to the east and um
you know i think sometimes it riles up
the wildlife uh-huh
okay
that doesn't sound good problem bear
oh god
uh does problem actually mean murderer
like how charles manson is a problem
cult leader
oh come on you just have to look for
tracks that's it uh-huh sure i've seen
what they can do to a tree and trees
aren't even food
thank you henry
okay yeah i'm your hero nine shining
armor gosh that's
odd now i got to think about the
repercussions of flirting with delilah i
mean obviously if you were in a
situation where you were isolated from
every other human being and there was
only one person that you could talk to
you might build a connection with them
especially if you both have
you know sad parts what is this hello
someone left their clipboard out here
doing studies and [ __ ] science
see if there's a name or a credential or
something i can call it
in uh how do i how do i
do i get do i put away this there we go
okay
what is oh
what was oh i saw the name jules on that
uh it's
holy [ __ ]
what's going on you didn't actually find
a bear did you
someone has written down what we said to
each other have been saying
that doesn't make any sense
uh i don't talk to the other lookouts as
much as i talk to you not in the same
way
no way
uh oh wait whoa hold on something's out
here whoa
what was that henry
i'm worried
yeah me too you didn't find and eat any
mushrooms did you i mean they can be fun
but also
you know
devastating
oh
no i did not just let me know okay
buckaroo okay bucca rooney i don't know
why i just called you that i don't know
either but let's just
ignore the flapjacks and buckaroonies
and let's just get on out of here what
is that oh
i found a walkie-talkie out here too
uh okay
it's going [ __ ] house
oh god
ow
why
why would you do that
are you there why would you do that
what happened henry oh gosh
i just i got hit in the head punched or
something by someone
are you serious what the hell is going
on out there i don't know jesus christ
holy crap let me get this straight you
found a clipboard with what transcripts
of our conversations what else is on it
i don't know it's gone along with the
radio of theirs
somebody out here could have just killed
me delilah
i don't
what the [ __ ] is going on what's wapiti
station
i i i i don't know
i saw the name wapiti station right
before i was cold cocked does boppity
station mean anything to you
um
whoppity meadow maybe it's swappity
meadow
it's it's on our maps it's not too far
from where you are right now it's where
you saw that damn fence it's north of
the lake it looks like there should be a
trail somewhere on the north shore of
jonesy lake
i'll i'll start hiking that way now god
damn it my head
are you
are you sure you saw what what you saw
henry maybe you pissed off some more
campers and they came back to sucker
punch you
there are people listening to our
conversations the person or these people
were hiding in the bushes down here what
the [ __ ] d
i don't know henry this sounds
crazy
yeah and you're not the one who just saw
our words on a clipboard out in in the
middle of nowhere
those words were from two weeks ago
no they were so
what's to say that they don't have
transcripts from three
four or five weeks ago
our entire relationship
friendship our whole summer
someone is out here with a walkie-talkie
taking notes and talking to god knows
who
uh it would be wise to leave out there
and get some answers
great
just keep a clear head don't you know do
anything crazy you might like taking a
job in the middle of nowhere with
literally no escape from whatever or
whoever is out there well
i meant like kill anybody you got it
boss
yeah you got it boss what the hell is
that is that always there did i leave
that there before i can't exactly
remember this is getting a little weird
this is getting a little disturbing i
mean we want two months
without actually you know
doing much
i'm not talking about that not talking
about that but i'm two months after the
girls went missing without doing much
and seeing a strange man and having
someone break into my own lookout tower
that seems like a lot of crisis
situations that should have been
addressed earlier than this i mean i
don't know how i could have slept
sounded like that well i wouldn't have
been able to but henry would that's
weird stacking
okay oddly intentional
good thing i have
enormous amounts of rope shoved up my
butt along with
turt reynolds and
i believe a box of supplies with food
beef jerky and prunes
but i'm not 100 sure about that hello
hi fence
okay i'm at the fence i don't see anyone
around but i'm not sure i can get past
it
how big is it big it goes off in both i
can't climb it it's impossible but what
the [ __ ] is going on out here
whatever it is someone doesn't want
anyone to know about it
sometimes biologists will cordon off a
little area to study flora or whatever
but
that's only a few square feet usually
that's not what this is
we'll see what you can do to get past it
maybe i could bash open the thing with
my thing and what are the odds they left
the gate unlocked
damn it that didn't work
man this will work eventually
okay how about tert reynolds maybe
that's gonna do something about oh
i can't get in look i'm not gonna be
able to get into this i'll never climb
it's impossible
how long i can dick around out here
until someone notices
god if you were an actual firefighter
you'd have that gate down in two shakes
hmm
hey actually those guys doing the
controlled burn they might be able to
help
where are they beyond ruby river there's
a scout camp they burned a line a few
days ago that should let you hike right
to them
well that's great
if they haven't left they're probably
the type of guys who would help you get
through that fence okay sounds good just
get the assistance of a bunch of burly
men okay where am i going
since josie river something river
i don't see names on this so i'm
assuming that's thunder canyon five mile
creek ruby river okay so i gotta go down
to the scout camp over there and i'm
guessing
either go to the medicine wheel whatever
the hell that is or
back to my lookout and drop down over
there either way that's where i gotta go
so i gotta go start going back so off we
go
into the weirdness i have no idea why or
how any of this is happening
why would anyone bother with that if
someone's got a fence cordoned off in
the middle of nowhere you know you'd
think that we in the lookout tower isn't
constantly going around here would have
noticed that because that's pretty
obvious
oh man this is the slowest silliest
climb i've ever done it's always good to
be completely perpendicular to the rock
wall when you're climbing it
okay good enough for me whoo
i'm too fat and old for this
okay anyway
they recorded our dirty talk they
recorded our sexy conversations i feel
so violated
turt reynolds i hope you didn't hear any
of that i heard everything mark you're
really weird and you have a lot of
fetishes that aren't listed on the
internet or the internet has all the
fetishes well you made some new ones and
it's really bizarre okay i'll be right
back
oh music kicked in does that mean that
something's happening
oh
i'm wandering around east of the lake
which way is ruby river it's in the
southeast corner of your map the scout
camp where the firefighters were staged
should be on your map it looks like a
little triangle with a flat bottom yeah
it looks like a tent how did i never see
that before
huh no way you've only been here for a
decade how did you not know okay so i
got to continue that in this way
and then oh oh i did lay a line over
there i'm assuming that it laid lines
imagining if throughout the two months
that i've been here already that i would
have traveled around here and used all
the plethora of robots i called around
things seemed normal with everyone else
should we call the cops or the forest
service and and let them know this is
going on
um
don't you think that would sound
you know
crazy
yeah it is crazy we have to tell someone
tell them what henry tell them we're
being stalked and you were attacked and
we don't have any proof
i don't know tell them we're being
bothered or something
henry i really like this job okay and if
i give off even a hint of cuckoo to my
bosses they are never gonna let me come
back out here do you understand that yes
all right i'm headed toward the camp
anyway
okay
keep your radio close to you will do
hey well you just said keep my radio
close to me
yeah before i got attacked back at the
lake i saw a radio on the ground kind of
like the one i use
and
do you think that maybe someone was
you know uh
i don't know
what
maybe intercepting our frequency with
other radios or something
henry
it's just a thought
i i don't even know how you would do
that you just yeah well you sound
worried
no i'm not okay let's not spin out of
control just keep hiking
whatever you say it's a radio it
broadcasts on a frequency and anyone
tuned into that frequency can pick it up
literally anyone that's not like a two
point like like zero point communicator
with quantum entanglement it's literally
on anything
but i don't have a good feeling thank
you i don't like feeling vulnerable
it's not like you can just call the
police
i was thinking about the good ones
it just struck me that
if anything weird like this happened to
them happened to brian
just how scared he would have been
yes thank you about talking about my
imminent demise
he had his dad to protect him
ned right
yeah you don't think he could
no you're you're probably right it was
three years ago he's in high school now
he's on summer break
yeah you're right you're right or am i
or is this the guy
i think it's called a medicine wheel out
here
yeah it was made by crow american
indians hundreds of years ago there are
lots of small ones um have you ever been
to medicine wheel monument over in the
big horns well i sure hadn't no well
it's worth a three-hour detour on the
way home in august uh neat i'll keep it
in mind
okey-dokey then i'm just gonna carry on
because that was probably something that
i should have discovered way earlier
than that and also thank you for talking
about all the paranoid you know cliches
talking about my demise and whatnot and
how soon i am to going home
i found where they did the controlled
burn uh i can hike right through here
now
normally they wouldn't do that so close
to a body of water but i think they're
extra worried about a fire jumping the
river and burning up to two forks
well i'm extra appreciative of that
let's see
the scout camp is southeast of the river
there should be a pond on the way
got it it's very beautiful what happens
if a controlled burn gets out of control
good question someone gets fired
wait yeah [ __ ] come on come on oh god oh
god oh god oh god come on
are you serious huh
off
okay
anything else of importance over here
no just a new area okay so that's the
controlled burn and then i just follow
the path down to the scout cap okay
sounds good to me i'm off
oh man
i mean there's obviously some secret but
maybe this kid that they keep talking
about and bringing up maybe he
has an obsession with delilah and has
just been living out in the woods
and stalking her and listening in to her
conversations and got very jealous of a
certain hank henry
talking to her lassie hey is that my
fishing pole
oh no that says well that's a ski
why is there a ski here
this isn't weird enough to report
it's
this is a little interesting don't you
think there's a ski in a big tree
boy i gotta pee
oh everybody look at me
oh i'm filled with such glee
oh that's oh yeah that's june fire okay
that way
why is that not important enough to
report that looks like straight out of
like you know straight out of uh maybe
it'd be better with the backdrop over
there maybe it'd be better with the fire
oh that'd be so good
let me see if i can get that shot
yeah oh that's so pretty oh god the
stupid rocks in the way oh that's a
bunch of baloney ah maybe the
composition of the rock is actually okay
that's pretty cool
that's pee cool
okay good enough hope that turned out
okay
my idea of good photography is probably
not analogous to analogous to everything
out there
to your guy's opinions i use big words
to cover up my stupidity that's what i
do and i'm gonna stop talking now
because i'm an idiot
all right anyway
are we almost there yet
maybe maybe
not hello
hello
kurt reynolds say something
now you're on your own this time thanks
turd that was such help to me oh god
why are there
ski-doos there's some old snowmobiles
out here
that's crazy
looks like one of the poor bastards was
cruising across this pond and dumped it
that was not a fun hike back to
civilization
whoa someone stripped these snowmobiles
down to the bone
that's weird right
i mean i can come up with a bunch of not
weird reasons someone would do that out
here but
given what's happened yeah
yeah that's weird
there's an old pond out here not much
more than a pile of mud
do you have it on your map
ah yeah i know where you are
yeah where am i pork pond there used to
be a sign up for it but um
well folks kept stealing it because of
the pork wow
because it's called pork pond
it's a good goddamn name that sign would
look great in a den or
you know anywhere
oh
someone was stealing it i know who
their name rhymes with myla
mamama
maflemela
magablaimlo
now it doesn't rhyme with magda blime
though i want to be very clear about
that camp
arapaho
camp arapaho
you're there oh yeah i am
it's been out there since the 50s
that's never really into the idea of
scouts oh no it's immense organizing
boys around their ideals or is that
right with me
we wear weebles in large numbers
beware of anyone in large numbers
well that's a little paranoid the bridge
to the camp is out damn of course i'm
gonna walk the ravine and see if i can
find some high ground to get across good
plan yeah i can only break my legs doing
that i could just you know go down a few
feet into the
ravine also known as a crick
you know not smash my face open on every
rock long drop down oh god no
maybe there's just a space over there
nope this is the only way
the only way possible
okay everything turned out okay
so i'm not gonna be able to get back am
i nope nothing about that
i mean i got a bad feeling about this i
mean i know i'm the only person out here
but why wouldn't me and delilah team up
and i'm not just looking for an excuse
to go to her lookout tower but it
doesn't look good you ever talk to any
of the scouts
no they haven't been out here in a while
and i generally don't have a lot to say
to pre-teens
i guess these little shelters are where
they keep the weeblows
for the past 35 years yeah
i see an axe over there
okay i don't think there's anything else
here unless there's something buried in
the rubble that's actually important to
a clue
but i doubt that very much and i don't
think there's a supply cash drop around
here nope okay what i'm gonna do is i'm
just gonna get this axe and i'm assuming
that the axe is gonna let me get into
the area
smash it up with rock ain't good enough
for anybody
oh
yeah these guys are gone i found where
they were sitting around before getting
picked up damn
i found a little trowel maybe i should
take it with me use it to pop open beers
wow um 99 sure that's for burying poop
and i'm holding it
i'm looking at it i'm looking at it very
closely it's even still got poop on it
why am i holding it
hey dee they left something behind it's
like a memo from their boss huh uh next
few days dropping into the thoroughfare
on behalf of dr simmons at
wapiti station
holy crap
keep reading
oh i just thought i would maybe you know
stop there let the mystery percolate my
mother always said i would need someone
to give me a taste of my own medicine
they're running a research site out
there uh he was worried about wildfires
someone is writing down our
conversations
and now we find out there's a research
site out here that that that we don't
know about what are they researching
uh you got me
us they're researching us
you think they're studying you and me
i do yeah i mean
maybe it's about
studying two strangers who talk every
day
like if you put someone in isolation
with someone else what they do
yeah that's what i think well [ __ ] that
agreed
i think we should allow for the
possibility that this is all just a big
misunderstanding but
god if you saw what you said you did
[ __ ] henry
yeah i saw it
okay
so what's next
i'm gonna do a scan for supplies and
then figure out a way to get back over
that ravine and hike towards the site
sounds good check in when you can and
keep an eye out for anyone following you
okay we'll do i mean all i see is the
poop trowel and the axe so uh i found an
axe
if one of the crew left it that thing is
actually called a pulaski
it looks like an axe to me this thing
will be a huge help
for both getting through the back
country and getting through that fence
yeah i'm out of here
i'm out of here baby i'm off with my axe
to axe that fence question
i blame
flabbler
okay
got it good
i'm a strong man
i don't think there's any other supplies
over there because they kind of set a
finality to those like i'm done i'm out
of here so oh i know what i can do here
head lip i'm an eco terrorist conch
blanc
smoke any day now
there we go
very scared about falling all those
branches were shaking and shimmying
okay
yep
very elegant definitely not a
40-something year old man
all right so there's got to be a
shortcut back straight to the tower or
not because there's absolutely nothing
but there's got to be something over
here because i would very much assume
that there could be something that
easily is overlooked maybe maybe maybe
maybe maybe maybe maybe oh gosh there's
nothing okay i guess i just got to go
back and confront these sun [ __ ] i
mean that would actually make sense if
they were doing a study about isolation
because
like maybe they had a bunch of reported
like suicides out here and whatnot oh i
i had a thought
let's hear it
you heard someone in the bushes
yeah
okay so let's assume we're being tailed
or you are at least where are you right
now
just on my way back in and out of trees
in the middle of nowhere fork pond do
you see anybody
no definitely not
all right so
tell me what you think of this
did you just cough no
did you just cough
no
oh [ __ ] [ __ ]
um
there isn't any way someone like another
lookout could be on this line is there
no
not without tapping our radios
what about when i heard you talking to
someone else
i just left your line open that's not
what this is
get in your tower shut the door don't
leave and don't use your radio
i'll call you
understand i will call you
okay then
you got me really creeped out here
thoroughfare tower this is two forks
calling you for the
oh 50th time today
the june fire continues to move in a
southerly fashion
delilah for [ __ ] sake answer your
radio
hello sunshine sorry i went out for a
little bit what can i do you for
uh
you can do me for a trip out of here i
don't care if it's on horseback or a
helicopter or in a canoe just get me out
of here hello bernie henry
we have work left to do let's chat about
what's bothering you and you'll feel
better are you serious
let's
talk
okay okay i get it uh okay
by the way i was wondering if your flora
of the shoshone info poster was still up
inside your tower
what it's just protocol that those stay
up you know info about your tower the
surrounding tree species etc
uh
uh all right
just
you know
have a look at it
make sure it's in shape i'm looking
right at it
okay yeah it's up why are you acting
like this
great just wonderful do you see the tree
in the top row second from the left
sure
it's the uh no you don't need to tell me
just um
internalize it it's a great tree and
there's an area called um
that tree's name in your sector that
maybe you should take a midday hike to
maybe
oh uh yeah okay but maybe i should go
for a hike
nothing like an afternoon in the rockies
i tell ya radio me the moment you get
there
oh he took off his ring
oh god
oh
uh i just meant to set it
i meant to set it gently on there
that's his decision not mine i could put
it back on
that'd be really sad
oh man is that is that important to
something bernie tell me what to do
i don't know
maybe you should decide for yourself
okay thank you you're of no help hey
turt reynolds can you tell me what to do
buddy
buddy
buddy
buddy no
no buddy
okay
well i meant to put him back but i guess
i'm taking him with me
okay all right then i'm gonna go out for
a hike so what i'm looking for is i'm
looking for
cottonwood
meadow
or cotton cottonwood creek okay that's
down right there by where i was okay so
i just that's that's not far am i going
to meet delilah there this is going to
be happy fun times
are we going to talk in person so that
we don't have to talk on the radio
anymore and then we're not going to be
you know eve drops all over
eve
stroops eve drops
you've dropped dropped it yes
southampton
all right i guess i'm on the way you
know this is really bizarre because it
seems like you know i was really like it
was getting me paranoid like right
before we skipped ahead in time it was
getting really paranoid like i was like
oh
[ __ ] something is about to go down and
now all this subterfuge is kind of like
deflating the air out of my balloon
well not really it's not really like
letting me down at all it's just like i
was like high tension right there it was
like oh [ __ ] things are about to go down
and not that i don't imagine that things
aren't still about to go down it's just
like
i was hoping the murderer would start
popping out of the woods on me
actually no that's probably not
something that i want to happen i would
rather not have murderers start popping
out on the woods all over me
i'd rather have nothing popping out all
over me
if i can help it also uh another thing
that this game reminds me of that kind
of just uh clicked with me is um did you
guys watch me play co-lot or play cola
for yourself because that was really
interesting in that
it was kind of like this i was exploring
an area and there was a map you know
reason that i could go around but also
it was like an interesting dynamic
because i was picking up someone else's
thoughts and then later in the game
someone started talking to me it
happened to be sean bean but um it was
just kind of like that but only in a
certain way it's not everything about
that
i just wanted to point out the
similarity there okay uh i'm here at
cottonwood creek
i said it you see the cash box there i
said that uh it must be around here
somewhere
it is
find it and open it i changed the code
it's five six seven eight
are you kidding me here
i was in a rush
so you came all the way out here
why did you say that
why'd you say that
you didn't come visit me
for shame oh hello
ah
ah
oh i've got it now
good i spent all day getting you that
radio
i hiked to a cash box lied to a ranger
lied to another ranger
and hopefully you are now holding a
clean untapped radio hopefully
holy [ __ ] henry we have to get into that
site why
are you okay are you okay i don't know
henry
people have been listening to us all
summer how is this actually happening
i don't know
i'm scared
are there any other lookouts this is
happening to
someone else in on this anyone
this is just happening to us everyone
else is fine
are you sure
yes
i've tried to bring it up to chimney
rock elks fork and beartooth lookout and
every one of them got confused
asked me if i'm okay and if i need to be
relieved
[ __ ] state coordinator asked if i was
just having lady troubles
so no this isn't happening to anyone
else and i'm done asking
i'm headed back to the gate and now that
i've got an axe we'll know something
soon
you need to get into that site call me
when you find something okay i mean it
seems a lot of me doing things and not
us doing things together i mean if
you're as worried about this as you
think and you came all the way out here
to drop it off in a box right a few feet
from my tower
uh
i just thought of something not um
not great what
what is it
i filed a report that said that neither
of us ever talked to or saw those
girls the ones that
went missing a few weeks back
oh [ __ ]
my thoughts exactly
our radios were tapped
and now someone probably has a
transcript of that entire conversation
and i've filed a report that's a blatant
lie
oh and those girls are still missing
yep
[ __ ]
[ __ ] indeed
we really need to get to the bottom of
this
yeah we kind of do i told you that it
was worth mentioning delilah turd
reynolds told you that it was worth
mentioning
why i trusted you okay which way am i
going on this one there's gotta be
there's gotta be more to that i mean the
girls have to be connected with this
somehow that's the only thing that
explains like those girls they had their
tent torn up they had their stuff stolen
ransacked whatever you want to call it
they were affected and there was a guy
that shone a light at me so it's all got
to be connected somehow and those girls
are like at the crux of it because they
went missing there's some people at
wapiti station the firefighters know
about the people at wapiti station what
does it all mean it's all connected
somehow but i'm not able to piece the
puzzles together and i have a sneaking
suspicion that delilah might know more
than she's letting on because it's easy
to be swept up in a romance when you're
completely alone and isolated and
desiring human you know uh comfort when
your wife is
suffering from alzheimer's at such an
early age and your life is in shambles
so i can see how he would be easily led
into this but
i i don't want to say it's as blatantly
obvious as that not that that's
incredibly obvious but you know you know
what i mean there's some there's
something going on here and i'm not able
to piece it together
all right here we go i'm busting the
gate down there's nobody around and it's
the quickest way in you got it
copy that oh yeah here we go and sorry
everybody i gotta end it here i'm
actually completely out of time danny's
about to come over in like 30 minutes so
i gotta get ready so thank you everybody
so much for watching i will pick this up
very soon and it'll probably be either
45 minutes to an hour so thanks again
and as always i will see you
in the next video
bye-bye
ride and make it
damn one hit kill
nothing